public live apparent the street oh it
says meaning is now streaming live on
YouTube okay cool
awesome do you want to just I'm gonna
tweet out at you
and then just maybe retweet it that'll
be good you know
tweet
yeah good all right so I just tweeted
that you you know I got it okay call so
we tweaked up let's see if it works I'm
gonna check my crew photo here see if I
see it me too no yeah it looks like
we're live awesome yeah so give that a
thumbs up
well Chris it's been a long time I
haven't seen you in person and what two
decades but remember I remember very
fondly interacting with you and uh I was
a professor Bob what was professors at
thank you Bob Matthew oh yes I love
fantastic guy we were in the class I
think you were an undergrad you were an
undergraduate
are you a graduate student back then oh
no I was I was a graduate student here
graduate said who was your advisor it
was it I just look very young I worked
with J Gallagher and also mapperchè D if
you remember those guys yeah of course
of course
so it's great to see you face to face
have a conversation with you and
definitely hopefully some folks out on
online on YouTube it's it's been you
know I followed your career and and of
course you know at one point we were
we're communicating locally because we
were in California together you are Cal
Tech as well mister around the same time
that I was there or maybe when I was
starting here and I think I think we had
you down here at one point
maybe when the burbage is were or so I
interviewed for a faculty job at UC San
Diego but unfortunately did not
unfortunately for us we'll say it like
that yes well we have great respect for
you and tell us a little quick bio of
where you are now in the UK and and then
what roles you perform there and are you
still editor of
J as you as you were what's your current
in a world line look like yep so I
currently a professor of astrophysics at
the University of Nottingham I've been
here since 2005 and my main research is
not on aliens or SETI or any of this
stuff this is um
what we're gonna talk about is a side
project for me which kind of became a
big big story but my main interest is
galaxies and galaxy evolution and that's
mostly what I've done throughout my
career is look at how galaxies change
with time did a lot with and do a lot
with the Hubble Space Telescope and I've
got lots of plans for James Webb and I'm
also the the lead editor for galaxies
and cosmology and the SS journals which
which includes the Astrophysical Journal
aha great and and you have as you said
you are not necessarily you know this is
not your day job typically to look at
these problems and and it's not it's not
kind of irrelevant to this time that
we're living in I always say you know my
show is completely apolitical I don't
talk about you know Republican
constellations or you know democratic
asteroids or whatever but this result
has generated so much intensity I think
I'm going to break the the political
forbidding political discussion and
we're gonna get into the details of your
new paper no I'm just joking it's it's
it's generating a lot of controversy as
you know and I think it's so that's good
that's good and some really fun
headlines
yes well such as I'm gonna choose one
the background let's see if this will
work replace my background with a with a
picture of you see if this works and I
have no idea what this says but but yeah
yeah it's gotta be galaxies something
about 30-something galaxies yeah I think
it's Turkish yes yeah actually I did
translate it but I forgot what it said
now he was nothing bad thank God my
friend okay or tener listening can you
guys please translate this so we're
gonna talk about this and we're going to
talk about the the actual
results in the paper and the details
that went into it and kind of let's
first start off because people I think
might be interested you said it's not
what you do you're normally a you know a
classical optical astronomer which means
that you look through telescopes as I
understand it true
no but you you you don't look through
them but you use them so tell us what
you'd normally search focus is first of
all my main research focus is
understanding how galaxies form so this
goes all the way back to the beginning
of where we can see galaxies read shifts
around redshift six seven maybe eight
perhaps nine sometimes depending on
whether or not you believe sources you
can find and that's basically when the
universe was 500 million years old and
then since then and so I look at how
galaxies have changed but in an
appearance hola to models out there that
predict how galaxies form but what I do
is actually look at the galaxies and
determine how they change so these
features are like their masses their
star formation rates how much merging
they have with other galaxies is
something I've done a lot in my career's
look at galaxy mergers and how they've
evolved through time sizes is another
big one I've done a lot of work with and
morphology just how they look so when
you put all this together and you can
trace how they changed through time for
galaxies of different sized stellar
masses or galaxies which you can trace
hopefully is the same type of galaxies
using like a number density selection
which basically means you just take the
most massive fraction to some density
limit and you assume that those galaxies
are at least statistically similar
through time then you can see how they
grow how other morphologies changes how
mergers are affecting the revolution and
if you like I haven't done much on this
but you could look at how aging and are
changing active galactic nuclei how
maybe their black holes have evolved
with the galaxies so it's a combination
of that process and that's basically
what I've been doing last twenty years
or so is looking at those questions so
is it safe to say this recent paper is
your lowest redshift result that you've
ever worked out you know that's a good
question I hadn't thought of that
probably yes on the planet
very astronomy recently because I know
I've never done the paper on on anything
planetary no so this must be the nearest
so there's been a lot of interest in
this paper I put a link in the show
notes or not in the show notes I will
someday put it in the show notes but
this paper and you have a wonderful
Twitter thread online about it of course
it's not without its controversy I asked
you if you if you had a chance to put
together a PowerPoint presentation do
you have any slides that you can show us
and let me them I'm just a very short
one okay good I'm gonna give you hosting
permission I need so I'm gonna go host
and people are asking if this is live
how do we prove its live without saying
a word that's band
well it's 6:30 to in sorry 1632 in the
UK and 832 833 in California hard to
make that up
alright you are now driving the the
PowerPoint bus to my friend let's do it
a roti let's see here you see this yeah
I do yeah okay
so I just have a couple slides and then
we can talk about talk about things so
this is the paper and it came out in the
journal Astrophysical Journal about a
couple days ago about about around the
15th of June and the title is the
Astrophysical Copernican weak and strong
limits for intelligent life okay and I
won't go read the whole abstract but
basically what we do is we essentially
ask the question how many intelligent
communicating civilizations might there
be in our galaxy based on just some very
simple assumptions and using recent data
about cosmology and about planets that
only appeared in the last say well four
planets the last decade with Kepler
mission but first a star formation rate
of our galaxy which is the last few
decades so a lot of this stuff is based
on an actual
it's metaphysics another one is the
metallicity of stars in our galaxy
something which has also been realized
and measured recently through surveys
looking at the spectra of stars
throughout our galaxy so that's
something else that's that's new here
and I'll come back to that in a second
so sorry Chris can you uh can you just
say a few words about your co-author is
that oh yes yes thank you very much yes
thank you
so Tom wispy is a he is a staff member
in the mathematics department at the
University of Nottingham and he's a is a
young guy he's younger than me so he
must be young right so well to
cosmologists everybody looks young yeah
right so tom tom is is a staff member
and he does some teaching in mass but he
doesn't have a PhD at least he doesn't
yet and he wanted to do a project so he
actually audited my galaxies class a
couple of years ago and he came up to me
and he says I would like to do Master's
on something like a terminal master so
he's not necessarily interested in doing
the typical you know do a page do you
try to find a postdoc he's got a job
already and he just wanted to do a
masters to get his feet wet doing some
astrophysics and I've always wanted to
do this project this is something that I
kind of always wanted to look into I've
been thinking about it for a long time
and now that I have a secure position at
least I think I do Tom himself is not
going to be on the you know the
Astronomy job market you know why not do
this this study which of course some
people won't like we already knew and so
that that's how that happened so tom is
not a typical PhD student he's terminal
masters so that's Tom and okay I'm sure
Tom will see this soon and thank you
very very much Tom because he did the
the bulk of the real work in this paper
for sure and then the last thing before
we move to the next side is what is he a
Copernican principle can you explain
to the audience who may not be familiar
with it and how it applies you know more
widely in in astronomy in the history of
astronomy that's a big part of this I
think yeah definitely so when when when
scientists first started asking
questions about the universe a the
ancient Greeks Aristotle in particular
came up with basically the the model of
the way we think about science for 2,000
years or so the idea was and this was
never really questioned is that the
earth is at the center of the universe
and everything revolves around it right
so you have the Sun the Moon the planets
stars all moving around in crystalline
spheres around around the Earth and that
wasn't that really wasn't changed until
Copernicus okay so Copernicus came up
with the idea most people will know this
that actually the Sun is the center of
the solar system and that the earth goes
around the Sun okay and at that time of
course they didn't make the big
conclusion that there was a galaxy no
cosmology and all this they just assumed
the Sun was the center of the universe
right and then it progressively became
less and less important in terms of
where we are in our galaxy in terms of
where we are in the universe and so
we're taking the next step in saying
that that essentially we're not special
in the sense that our formation as a
intelligent species on this planet isn't
special but that in fact it's just a
natural part of the scientific process
okay so that's basically the idea and
the weak and the strong limits are
having to do with how that life forms so
another planet so the strong limits are
that it forms exactly the same ways it
did on earth the same amount of time the
same metallicity that we have on our
planet and the weak limits is where you
relax that condition of time and where
you need just the amount of time that we
did form which is about four-and-a-half
billion years
what can happen anytime after that it
doesn't have to happen at that time so
the strong is it happens at about five
billion years but the weak is that it
just needs four and a half to five
billion years but
time after that he can they can form it
can happen like a nine billion years you
just need at least that amount of time
so that's the weak aspect of it and of
course you'll find more of these
proposed civilizations in the weak
criteria dan you doing a strong
yeah just for my audience out there
we've done a lot of talks over the last
six to nine months that revolve around
either
SETI in this case caddy I believe is how
you pronounce it and and also we've
looked at the question of origin of life
we've had guests on from Scripps
Research Institute origin of life the
role the chirality plays in life and
that cute connection to knobs and premio
Lebow prima liebe liebe levy and we had
a nice discussion about that and I and
earlier this year we had on Paul Davies
and Jim Benford and others discussing
you know 60 years of the Drake Equation
almost 60 years of at least searching
for extraterrestrial intelligence SETI
and and kind of eerie silence as Paul
Davies describes that you know so so
yeah let's go to your next slide which I
believe involves the Drake Equation yeah
yeah so this is the famous Drake
Equation which a lot of people really
hate and I'm not a big fan of it either
and let me explain why okay so the Drake
Equation essentially is does the same
kind of thing that we did but it looks
at things a little bit differently and
one of the things it does is it has the
this here's the equation right here this
n is a number of civilizations and you
have all these terms I'm welcome to come
and go through all of them but I'll put
off point out a few of them are is the
average star formation rate in the
galaxy so that we don't use but the ones
that are really kind of let's say I
don't know the right word for but
annoying frustrating with the big
equation is it has these terms the
fraction of those planets of planets
that are round a star that can develop
life at some point fraction that develop
intelligent life fraction of intelligent
life that that releases signals and
these three terms here are really
impossible to know unless you actually
detect life
the Drake Equation cannot be used really
as something predictive because those
numbers can range from zero to two one
and they could just know that and as I
have a talk I was honored to give a talk
once at the SETI Institute where the you
know Frank Drake is the basically the
you know the most high priest of that
and Jill tarter his is worthy is worthy
equal and I went over the Drake Equation
I said and maybe Chris tell me if you
agree if one of your students handed in
an equation and it just had these
numbers and nothing else and I think
this is the big thing that's missing
from all the popular media accounts of
your paper that causes a lot of the
controversy
what grade what mark what do you call it
in England Mark's mark yeah yeah so what
kind of mark would he or she get if if
this is exactly the equation that they
turned in with no nothing else
associated with it yeah you know it's a
good question you never hear the
uncertainty bar you never hear this
equation basically can have you know a
hundred percent uncertainty in it now
we've we've actually reduced
dramatically the uncertainty on some of
these parameters and your actual day job
research is responsible for part this
you know the first term also star right
our star is a cosmologist quantity let's
call it and then F of P also we we
didn't know that looks like twenty years
ago but we know this not from Kepler
yeah so we know that a couple of these
things that we didn't know certainly
didn't know 60 years ago with when Frank
Drake first proposed this equation so we
do know some of the terms but as I said
some of them we will never know until we
actually detect life and then have a
statistical sample of planets that we
know don't have life and ones that we do
and then we can measure these terms so
they they are terms that are in
principle real but there's no way of
knowing it until you actually detect
life right so that's the problem with
the trig equation I think you would
agree right yes I do agree and and I
always like to point out the
uncertainties what you do a very careful
I mean I think the bulk of the paper is
the error analysis which hopefully we'll
get into in the next couple
slide so yeah let's let's go to the next
one yeah cool so this is our new Chet
equation and essentially what we do is
make that assumption that I already
discussed this astrobiological
Copernican principle where it takes at
least five billion years or so for life
to form okay and then so we have a
different equation where from the star
formation rate history we know what this
end star in this equation is this is the
N is the number of civilizations that
are actively sending out signals into
space and star is a number of stars
within the galaxy which actually is part
of the biggest part some of the biggest
part of the certainties in this is that
numbers it's something that I was quite
surprised looking into this is that was
isn't something that we know very well
is the number of stars in our in our own
galaxy there's still quite a bit of
uncertainty about that but anyway yeah
we've talked about that if you want but
it's just something to do with the dust
in the galaxy it makes it hard to see
things very familiar invest and the
problems it causes yeah yeah you know
well to write F of L is the fraction of
the stars which are older than five good
years so this is certainly a different
term than anything you haven't Drake so
this says what what fraction of the
stars are older than five good years and
that's something that we wouldn't have
been able to calculate even you know
twenty years ago but because we know a
lot about the history of the star
formation or galaxies and other galaxies
we know how old the stars are and within
within galaxies statistically at least
we don't know exactly every stars age
but we know the star formation history
so we get some idea of of how how many
are older than five gig years yeah okay
and then F of H Zen or H Hz if you're in
America which is the fraction of those
stars which have a basically a planet in
the habitable zone and that's something
that we recently realized or calculated
from the Kepler mission so that's a big
part of this is knowing that
yeah that is something that we didn't
know at all until two maybe five years
ago even even kind of a good hint okay
let me go on so F of M is the fraction
of stars which host a metal which planet
metal-rich is defined in many different
ways so if you want a star like our Sun
that it would have to be solar
metallicity obviously which is actually
quite rare in our own galaxy maybe only
ten fifteen percent of stars are that
metal-rich at most but you can use other
metallicity too and we actually do that
in the paper if we go into some depth
about looking at the distribution of
metallicity x' and assuming different
metallicity x' for that fraction then
the other thing which is different is
this thing tau which is the average
amount of time in which life could have
formed on that star so that is basically
going to be that the age of the star
minus five gig years and so that tells
you how long has a how long how much
time is elapsed on that planet since the
potential formation of life which we
assume has to happen within five gig
ears or sorry after five gears and so
that that's basically the amount of time
you have or you've had have to form life
if you need five gears to form life and
then L is similar to the drag equation
is the average lifetime of a advanced
civilization and this is the one this is
probably the most interesting aspect of
all of this is that that that quantity L
is the average lifetime of civilization
which is able to transmit signals
essentially that we could detect yeah
and that can be anything that can be in
principle like radio waves it could be
you know lasers some people are going to
look for lasers with SETI now it could
be things like even things like said
light from cities or something like that
which in principle you could detect if
you had the right technology so that's
basically it and nothing Chris has to
deal with the probability for life to
form and then once life forms then it
has to become not only sentient
conscious like a dolphin but it has to
have technology so that's that's all
subsumed
the assumption that the lifetime is
predicated on the existence of a
technologically capable civilization is
that right that's right so it makes the
assumption here which is that this is
this is one of the key things about this
is that if you have a planet in a
habitable zone which is metal rich
enough and you give it enough time on
say a stable star then it will form
intelligent life that's a big assumption
I I totally accept admit that it's a big
assumption now and you can you can say
well that's probably not true and it
probably isn't true right to some extent
that probably isn't true but would say
you have to start somewhere you have to
ask these questions somewhere you have
to start by solving this kind of
equation you want to call it like a
Drake like equation if you if you want
that's fine but if you want to start
asking how many of these civilizations
could we have in our galaxy you have to
start somewhere so this is really the
first attempt to do this by it by saying
that if you have the right conditions
you form life yes the new form
intelligent life and we could be rare we
could be the only the only civilization
in our galaxy and in fact before I
started this I thought that was the case
and and and I was actually thinking that
I would find that you did this
calculation day you would get one or two
or something very small plus or minus a
huge number and therefore hey where the
you know it's unlikely that or it's
unlikely that there are other
civilizations in our galaxy because look
at this number when you assume that all
all all planets that could host life do
you still only find a couple right
that's what I was thinking I would find
but we got we got something which is
bigger than that it's not a much bigger
but it's still a few dozen in terms of
the principle result it has an error bar
on it which goes down to a few goes on
to two essentially what the error bar so
we could still be the only only
civilization but the key aspect of this
is not that we were trying to say there
are 36 civilizations in our galaxy
because it's not what we're saying but
we're saying I make this assumption this
is what you get and if you
think that that life is different from
say and they know it could very well be
right
if life forms in a different way then
say a how a planet forms how a galaxy
forms how a star forms but right if you
have the right conditions for forming
those things you formed them right if
you had a gas temperature density you
form it right life gonna be different it
probably is different to some extent but
if you take it just a hard scientific
approach to it then that the formation
of life and the formation of intelligent
life is somewhat inevitable given the
right conditions just like everything
else in science and this is what you get
so that's really kind of what we're
saying here so I start getting some
questions in the comment section about
whether or not this metal-rich attribute
is the you know is kind of a requirement
could you have a you know is well first
of all explain what a metal is to a non
astronomy but second of all what is a
you know it's Jupiter Jupiter count as a
metal rich planet I mean could you have
not only a a gas giant planet but what
about a moon around a gas you know do
you have to go even further down the
rabbit hole and calculate the moons that
could possibly have hide metal content
as well so first of all what's a metal
and second of all you know do moons
count and gas giants etcetera
yeah okay the metal thing this is
something that annoys me still
so I'm so conditioned now to to to what
a metal is in astronomy that forget that
other people civilians let's call them
don't actually know what I mean by a
metal and what other astronomers mean by
a metal so a metal of course if you take
chemistry in high school metal is like
iron you know lead right makes sense but
to an astronomer a metal is any element
heavier than helium okay and when I tell
my students that in my galaxy's class
they all laugh and and fair enough right
because that's not the definition that
anyone else uses but astronomers do use
that so bimetals I mean things like
carbon nitrogen oxygen things that you
need to form like
okay so anything that is heavier than
helium is so that's what I mean by a
metal so now due to the s back to uh
Jupiter Jupiter is not keep this a
wooden host wouldn't us life but also
it's it's not in the habitable zone now
when you talk about moons stable so
hopefully it won't disconnect we lose
that certainly it's a possibility right
and there are moons in our own solar
system that people about sorry Chris
having a little trouble standing yeah
can you hear me do you hear hear me i I
it's intermittent it's a little spotty
yeah
go ahead let's see let me see maybe can
you stop what happens if you stop
sharing your video okay now it's it's a
little better yeah maybe truck can you
try stop sharing your video I don't know
if that I'll cancel the screen share I
hope it doesn't let's try it no that was
not good that kicked him off I think he
ended the stream instead of just
switching off as a video see if we can
get him back there he is
hello Chris another one back no it's a
little better I was well let's try it
let's go back the other thing I was
saying is if you stop sharing your video
your live video I think it'll still
share the screen but let's let's give
that a charge just so that we don't tax
the bandwidth not sharing my my own
video of myself yeah okay alright and
then sugar screen again yeah can you do
that yeah all right perfect
yeah it sounds a lot better now about
that I have what's called Virgin Media
which is a
we're so apologize for that
okay where was I oh yeah the moons right
so is it working okay now it's a little
better yeah it's can you hear me hello
yeah I could tell on my phone if that
continues to be bad so alright so moons
moons couldn't indeed have a potential
for life now about intelligent life you
know we're getting into the realm of
science fiction so who really knows
right but what we did in this and this
is really wanted to focus this just on
things like us things that form sort of
similar to us you can always come up
with with different ways of forming life
which differ from us and that could very
well be the case too but we really
wanted to just start with this basic
idea of looking at things which would
resemble the way that we formed so
that's really the point of this I hope
that got through yeah it did
yep yeah let's go to the next leg all
right all right so this just shows I'm
not gonna go into these in detail some
of the data so the top one is the star
formation rate that we assume for our
galaxy so here you can do things like
integrate this to get ages of stars and
we did a lot of that to figure out the
ages of stars and how they're
distributed at the time then here you
have a table which shows the current
rate of terrestrial sized planets within
the habitable zone and this is work from
different studies listed there for FG K
and also M stars this shows this
quantity for FGM how where we derive it
from these papers so this these are
really critical papers for this for
forgetting this fraction and ultimately
what we did by integrating essentially
the values from these two different
papers and looking at the distribution
of stars of course the M dwarfs will
dominate number and we can come back
talk about that again as well because
it's very interesting issue as well the
endorsed dominate but when you just do
the correct integration basically of
multiplying the the fraction
with the number of stars are likely to
see then you get you get a value a point
not one nine which is what we use in our
study and it has some uncertainty there
as you can see the bottom one is the
metallicity distribution four stars that
are greater than the solar metallicity
so those are stars that have a mini
Lissa T and remember metallicity is
anything heavier than helium and it's a
function of distance from the galactic
center and also a galactic scale height
it was a question I had if it's not not
all radii are equal in the galaxy we
write the galaxies basically you know
pancake plus a bulge and so you know do
you couple in galactic longitude with
Galactic latitude or is it just
basically you know distances distance
because we we do both so we have a big
table on our paper listing what these
these fractions are on different parts
of the galaxy and we know that the
density distribution of stars so we're
able to put all that together basically
another integral and therefore come up
with the creb metally
distributions of the number of stars at
a given metallicity by taking into
account the distribution of medalists
see changes as a function of the
position in the galaxies do that great
okay yeah then finally I'm not gonna I
would I didn't want to show the math on
this too much for the other plots but if
you look at me stars in our C ear what
you find is that this time of stages of
stars after about five billion years is
about is about four point eight billion
years so the average age of a star in
our galaxy is about nine point eight
billion years so if you subtract five
from that you get four point eight which
is how long in we criteria of the
Copernican principle astrobiological
Copernican principle how long you have
had to form this an intelligent
communicating life is four point eight
billion years on average for four for a
star in our galaxy
should I move on or you have any
questions oh that's great yeah we had
that one one person the comments is
saying you know murphy's law must be
scientific because it's saying that and
anything can go wrong will go wrong and
a lot of these stars are hidden by dust
on the other side of the cause of the
galaxy he's just making a joke yeah it's
very good we're true yeah it's always
there's always a problem that's actually
there's a meme on on the internet you
know it's like when they do a trial and
they say something causes cancer or
cures it or whatever and then that the
meme is you know just say in mice and
then I feel like saying you know for
things like a tabby star or whatever you
know just say with dust or a strong yeah
let's go to the next one all right cool
so this is my final special make sure
this is my final slide and you know if
people listening are really interested
in this I encourage them to look look at
the paper I think that anyone with the
scientific basic scientific background
would understand this stuff there's a
lot in here but I will go through just a
bit of it so essentially we have this
week and then we have a moderate and
strong criteria and those are the
criteria there we have categories 1
through 12 where 12 is the say the
strongest which is where the planet in
life are forming on something which is
exactly the same as on earth and then on
the right you see the table which has
those categories again and then there's
that 30 step famous 36 number in the
bottom the bottom left of that table
and essentially also gives us the mean
the maximum distance to the nearest
neighbors and you can see based on the
criteria of different metallicity x' and
different lifes life times in terms of
how long you might have formed a
civilization so again the weak criteria
here 4 5 & 6 this is where the age is
greater than anything or than 5 years so
you're looking at anything greater than
5 five good years now I should say that
these numbers are based on this is this
is getting to that elf thing on the
assumption that the average lifespan of
an intelligent communicating
civilization is a hundred hundred years
so that's how long we basically have
been communicating and releasing radio
waves into space so to speak for is
about a hundred years so that is really
a lower limit why is it yeah yeah
exactly so why is that I mean what
what's on the other side of that is that
you know we we destroy our civilization
or that we go to fiber optics you know
we only use you know mass broadcasting
of power for a long for a short time
even out of the hundred years that we've
been using it and now we use fiber
optics and we use beam formed Gaussian
beam transmission that's very
directional so we didn't really expect
you know that if it's dominated by kind
of just you know broadcasting in the
literal sense of chucking everything as
a you know a single point radiator it
mainly may be an under estimate right I
mean we may actually be able to
broadcast for a lot longer without
actually having to assume that we kill
ourselves after a hundred years or
hopefully not yeah yeah yeah definitely
so we we still have some signals going
in space like radar or things like
sharks will be transmitted indirectly
and they you can argue mobile signals
that kind of thing could also in
principle go into space stuff happening
the key thing about this is that this
this is the limit based on how long
we've been around right and how long
we've been communicating out into space
so to speak so if you think as a
civilization
the average civilization communicating
civilization in our galaxy would be much
longer than 100 which we hope it is
because we hope that we survive more
than hundred then these numbers would go
up by that by the proportional amount
yeah okay in this calculation of course
and that's what scientists mean when
they say a lower limit it means it's
likely not to be smaller than the value
quoted and it's a contra distinction to
an upper limit which is it can be no
larger than at least based on our
evidence
yes exactly and one of the key things
about this is that we talked about is
that by looking forward to doing SETI by
looking for civilizations transmitting
and finding them we would actually be
able to say something perhaps about our
own existence in the sense that if a
intelligent species has the same
characteristics throughout the galaxy
let's say then the ability to make a
high technology and to transmit signals
would certainly go along with the
ability to to destroy itself in many
different ways and I won't go through
them all here but you can imagine what
some of those are and if we find that
there are many civilizations throughout
the galaxy I agree that's unlikely now
we've seen something probably that it
would be a sign that this l value how
long that we or how long an average
communicating civilization last could be
quite long so the higher the density of
civilizations
the better odds we have of being around
for a much longer period of time mm-hmm
alternatively the other thing I want to
point I want to make about this is that
let's say in some time in the future we
have scanned the entire galaxy we've
seen every star and we've determined
that there absolutely is no intelligent
life communicating on any of these stars
throughout our entire galaxy well I
would argue that's that's a very bad
sign for our own existence simply
because if if if things did develop
communicating intelligence did develop
they're all gone now and that means that
they have gone extinct they've most
likely destroyed themselves or if you
wanted perhaps are destroyed by
something astronomical which is another
possibility but anyway they haven't
survived for very long and that would
that would mean that we may not actually
survive for very long either so by
looking out and trying to find these
things we're actually looking at our own
future but with the caveat that if we
don't find anything it also may mean of
course that we are very unique and that
our formation happened maybe in a random
way or just got we got very lucky maybe
or if you're religious maybe you think
that you know something to do with God
or you know something religious made us
happening on planet earth so yeah you
know this has profound implications so
the point of this study is really to say
if other civilizations could last for at
least a hundred years and they form the
same way we do how many would we find
right and so you find at least 37 well
you kind on average 36 from savings we
should find on average about 36 based on
our calculation so the point of this is
that in the future when people start
asking these kind of questions they can
go back to this paper that we've written
and use this sort of as a baseline for
trying to understand more maybe more
complex questions or and when we have
more statistics from steady and that
won't be for a long time I understand
you know we can compare what we're
finding empirically with what you would
expect just based on very simple
assumptions and if you find something
different from this then it tells you
that something about your assumptions is
wrong which is very important because
the assumptions that we're making are
really critical for how life forms and
it's it's be very different and so by
comparing we're effectively being able
to learn something very profound about
our own existence both how we formed how
we evolved on earth but also how long we
might survive as a an intelligent
species which is a very important thing
so yeah I'm always reminded of the words
of John Muir who's we have a college I'm
actually in the John Muir College at UC
San Diego we have a college system not
unlike you guys do in the UK but he said
you know by by looking out and going out
into the wilderness I realized we were
really going in and it's sort of
possible to do a little self exploration
whenever we contemplate these big issues
these are really the ultimate issues and
we don't spend that much time talking
about it and then when scientists do it
very courageously and and so forth as
you and your colleague have done you
know it sparks a lot of passion and
interest and just in the last few
minutes I know it's late there and
it's early here but we they still there
yeah yeah hi mom we have we we have a
deep interest in these in these
questions and we also like to talk about
the the controversy if you will and you
know I think not very few things
engender controversy as much as thoughts
of us being alone completely alone or
not alone I'd like to point out I don't
know if you read this book by Adam Frank
is a professor in New York State here
and the U in the u.s. he has a book a
light of the Stars where he instead of
using radio communication he basically
claims that greenhouse gas emissions
would be a signal signature of life and
he goes through and comes up with a
calculation with how many civilizations
have existed I believe in all of cosmic
history and all throughout the entire
observable universe and I believe if
anybody's listening I don't know he's
not a subscriber as far as I know but
but in his book he I believe the number
of civilizations in all of history
throughout the observable you know it's
like 22 or something I don't know if you
read his book and there's much talk
city's given yeah it's it's a really
interesting book but he also comes up
with kind of a conclusion you know first
of all the numbers are I mean it would
if you just scaled from our galaxy to
the observable universe etc you probably
have a hundred billion you know more
factor more in the observable universe
and these are currently existing
civilizations Cresson your model these
would be currently exist yes yes yeah
the important thing is that these are
currently existing that that in
principle we could detect of course if
something the problem with this though
is that the if there's really 36 let's
say then the average distance would be
seventeen thousand light-years so if
something there has existed 400 years
say then we might not necessarily see
the signal right if it's so far away so
by the time we did they would be long
gone right and the messaging back and
forth and of course there's controversy
about that I'm curious what is your
perspective on messaging to
extraterrestrial civilizations your your
countryman Stephen
walking warned against that right it
could be like inviting you know inviting
hungry hungry people to dinner where you
know being served as the main course I
actually don't
I actually don't agree with that I think
that if if a civilization is able to
contact us and to say come and come and
come to us that they would have mastered
the way of having a high technology
without without destroying themselves
then they would have found a way to do
that and so you would think that they
might actually be more reasonable than
to just come in to another place and
just destroy everything I think that's a
little unlikely but who knows that may
they may come down and eat us tonight
who knows and what is the closest
civilization what say the mean or the
average distance to the civilizations
what's sort of like the most proximate
one to us if you do the if you do the
strong Copernican limit then the nearest
one would be seventeen thousand
light-years mm-hmm so yes yeah quite a
distance you know quite a long time to
wait for a penpal
male to arrive yeah so we have other
people commenting and one of my
undergraduates looked into this question
and he found an article I'm not going to
promote it too much as I think the
attacks were a little bit at home and in
which I don't care for but it was a
rebuttal to the argument and the
author's case calls for an end of
biological speculation by physicists and
that but I think you made the case
earlier it really isn't predicated on
the formation of life that's why I asked
that question you know I always very
respectfully will push back but I think
you know that's really the key and I
guess you know I'm curious if you have
to say right now what what is the
resolution of the Fermi paradox in your
opinion assuming this work is and they
think it's reasonable I will ask you
first let me ask you what's the Fermi
paradox resolution the most likely one
in your estimate
well I think the the Fermi paradox which
for people who may not know that is the
question is why haven't we seen aliens
if they if they've existed the galaxy is
you know 13.7 billion years old 13.8
maybe or so billion years old so why
haven't we seen them yet
and I think the resolution has to be to
some degree that that lifespan of
civilizations isn't isn't super long
right so if you've had that much time to
form civilizations and for them to
evolve talking billions of years I mean
the the if you look at when
civilizations could have formed in our
galaxy the peak of them would have
formed like five billion years ago so
because of the way to star formation
history of the galaxy is right we're
very much late comers in our galaxy's
history by definition to some extent but
still if you look at the fraction of
stars form but most of them are formed a
long time ago therefore and they had
plenty of metals so you could have
formed and probably did form some life
back then so and you could say well why
why you know if they if they they could
go extinct for various reasons they
destroy themselves and that's fine but
if you have a if you have a super
high-tech civilization I would expect
that they would find a way to to to
colonize other stars or planets but also
more interestingly and more likely
probably is to form you know
self-replicating machines that can then
colonize the galaxy and over billions of
years you can do a lot of stuff I mean
oh yeah you know that's a long time we
can't really even imagine what that is
as humans how long that is so that's I
think is one version of it another
version might just be that because the
lifetime may not be very long that
actually any active ongoing
civilizations are just very far away
why couldn't calculation that we did and
therefore very unlikely that they could
travel here very unlikely that we could
detect them and they wouldn't detect us
because we've only been transmitting a
hundred years so our
our transmission bubble is only a
hundred years in radius right so there's
unlikely to be anything within a hundred
light years so why you know why would we
expect anyone to have seen us
likewise for them perhaps so I want to
close the conversation this isn't our
typical I usually do what are called
into the impossible podcast these are
usually with authors of books etc but at
the end so the the name of the center
here is the arthur c-- clark center for
human imagination and we typically at
the end of my conversations with authors
i asked them questions related to the
the so called three laws of arthur c
clarke which is that you know first one
any sufficiently advanced civilization
is indistinguishable from magic or
technology is indistinguishable from
magic to which my friend michael shermer
on a podcast i did with him recently
said any sufficiently advanced
technology is indistinguishable from
aliens or any sufficiently alien
technology is indistinguishable from God
but instead of going there and while we
wait for your book to come out hopefully
is is the question I asked folks related
to our thirsty Clark's 2001 a Space
Odyssey turned into a movie by Stanley
Kubrick
featuring these famous monoliths these
monoliths discovered on the plains and
the savannahs of Africa by early
hominids and then later discovered on
the surface of the Moon and I always
like to ask my guests if you had a
billion year long lasting time capsule
something that would convey a message a
warning hope or a future message to the
future
what would professor constantly sleeve
on his monolith oh that's the good
question I have never really thought of
that would I I don't know I certainly
would say something about that we were
here once I know that's lame answer but
that's what comes in my mind
assuming they could read it you mean I
guess yeah that's right if you put it on
a cd-rom it might not be so readable I
had on Andrew
and her podcast will come out soon and
she actually did this I mean she had
that was responsible for the Voyager
records and putting on everything from
you know her brain waves and their
heartbeat when she fell in love with
Carl Sagan all the way to putting on
world music from Ghana and all sorts of
other places around the world so it was
quite quite a lovely thing to actually
talk to somebody who had actually done
that send something into space that'll
probably have that she claims as a four
billion a year long life span so she may
last two you know star that's being born
now in the console east model may by the
time it's discovered this Voyager record
may have a life form that we can
communicate with Chris what's next for
you and we're where can people find you
on the web and Twitter etc yeah so my
twitter my handle is just my last name
which is con Solis and I I don't have
really a blog or anything like that but
yeah Twitter is basically where I where
I would post most things that people
might find of interest to me so what's
next so I'll be doing a lot more work
and galaxies I have certainly a lot of
things coming out with that I have many
PhD students doing great work with with
that so interested in galaxies I don't
have a book on galaxies which you can
look up on Amazon which is very very
interesting about the history of
galaxies so there's nothing to do with
aliens though well I do have a one
little one little SETI thing that I
worked on with some undergraduates again
and this might be the end of my my um my
dipping into this subject we'll see but
I'm looking for like galaxy-wide kind of
alien archaeology we did have I did have
a conversation with Greg James Benford
about this very subject so lurkers in
the soul and so I refer people to the
conversation we had back in January
about this very topic actually yeah
there's a there's some thoughts that
there are these kind of Earth's Earth
trailing Earth orbit trailing lib
point bodies that are big enough to
support maybe a monolith or something
else but some kind of archaeological
structure so I'll put a link to you and
then in the chat watch tonight I haven't
seen it yeah yeah please do put the book
in thank you yeah I'm interested in more
large scale like in other galaxies and
stuff and it'll there's I think a good
argument for thinking that the city
might be found actually external
external galaxies before it's found in
our own galaxy for various reasons but
maybe we can talk about that some other
time
but but I have some wonder guys look
into this look and we didn't find
anything spoiler alert but there's a
paper or paper on a loom one day that's
great Chris I really appreciate you
spending time with us congratulations on
the fascinating result time will tell
we're going to come back for Redux of
this in 17,000 years and be able to
revise the limit upwards and I just want
to caution people out there there's a
lot of takes and I know you felt it was
a little bit science journalism is
unfair and you add a great you had a
great quote you know like we need to
teach how to use the latex you know plus
minus symbol and all and and I think you
know that you that it is a service to
provide that you have to always when
you're out there listening and you're
talking to lay people who are you know a
lot of times science journalists are not
experts in science that you really do
want to associate what are the limits of
our knowledge not just our knowledge but
the limits of our knowledge and I think
you did a great job in that I put a link
to your discussion with dr. Becky on
that as well
oh I don't think I've talked to her
about this but oh well if she had a link
about this is it some my other result
which is on the earliest stars forming
okay I thought okay I'm miss ready okay
good but you do so yeah so you have had
that people should look at that too
because that's that's also very
interesting yeah and I'm gonna put a
link to my talk at SETI where I go
through the Drake Equation and hopefully
people can check that out I'd be
interested to get your thoughts on that
too especially since it relates to I do
a calculation not of
alien occupation of Earth but of what is
the current occupation well this is four
years ago now it's basically zero but
what was the population of the San Diego
Zoo because I believe them at the
resolution of the Fermi paradox is the
so-called zoo hypothesis but well we'll
have to take up talk about that I'm not
you know um the logarithmic you know one
over the you know ten thousand times
knowledgeable as you are Chris I want to
thank you so much it's great to see you
you turn aliy interesting creative and I
thank you also for the service that you
do for astronomy it's one of the highest
impact journals in the world highest you
know certainly in astronomy the whole
journal of portfolio and someday I'd
like to talk about you know journals the
history of the future of journals the
history of journals peer review etc so
but again congratulations thanks for
staying up and I wish you all the best
and thank you for inviting me I had a
good time the fun okay bye guys bye
Chris bye everyone